CLAUDIO CHERUBINO:
Hi, everyone.
Welcome back to Google
Developers Live.
My name is Claudio.
I'm one of the engineers on the
Google Drive SDK Developer
Relations team.
And today, I'm going to do a
review of an application that
very recently, just last week,
at the end of last week, was
released on our Chrome Web
Store on a collection of
Drive-enabled application.
This application is called
Spreadshirt Designer for
Google Drive.
Many of you might know
Spreadshirt already.
It's a well-known product that
allows anyone to go on their
web page and design their own
T-shirt mug, hat, any kind of
promotional items or gadgets
or clothing where you can
print something on it.
So you can have your own
personal design.
And the new thing, what they
just launched, is a way for
you to upload your files
directly from Drive.
So, for instance, you can have
your own image that is on
Drive, or that someone shared
with you and use it to be
printed on your T-shirt.
We wanted to show you this
application because we have a
lot of applications that do a
lot of creative things with
the Drive API, and we think
this is one of them.
This is something that goes
beyond your computer.
So you start from the computer,
and you get a real
object, a real item that
can use your files.
Let's see how this works.
The application is new
and is available in
the Chrome Web Store.
I have the listing page
in front of me.
What we can see here,
there is a number of
screenshots and a video.
The flow is that you install the
application, grant access
to it, and then you can pick any
of the files you have on
your Google Drive account,
and send it directly to
Spreadshirt.
There's some small things we
would like to be improved or
changed, and I'm going
to address all of
them, one by one.
So if you open the Chrome Web
Store and you check this
collection, the Drive
collection, it will find this
application.
When you click on it, you will
see this listing with some
screenshots to show how to use
the application, and what the
final result could
be, and a video
explaining the same things.
You can also check
the reviews.
The application still has a
small number of reviews, but
they're all positive.
So we are confident this
application will be liked by
many of you.
As usual, the selection process
is very, very easy.
You just open the listing like
I've done, and then you have
this big blue button that
says Add to Chrome.
If I click on it, I have to
confirm that I want to add
Spreadshirt Designer
for Google Drive.
I say Yes.
That's the only step required
to install an application.
The result, if you're using
Chrome, is that a Spreadshirt
Designer icon is added
to your new tab page.
Remember, you can add Drive
applications using any
browser, not just Chrome.
So if you visit the Chrome Web
Store, let's say with Firefox
or Internet Explorer, you can
still install the applications
on your Drive account.
The only difference will be
that, of course, there will be
no Spreadshirt Designer icon in
your new tab page, because
each browser has its own concept
of new tab page.
This is something that is very
Chrome specific, but this is
not a requirement.
We would like to stress this,
because this is a common
question we get.
So the takeaway is that you can
install Drive applications
using any browsers, and you
can use those applications
with any browsers.
So if I click on this now, what
happens is that I'm taken
to a Spreadshirt page that
explains what you can do with
Spreadshirt and how to use
it integrated with Drive.
Their instructions are easy.
You start from Drive.
You select a file you want
to use with Spreadshirt.
Then you're brought to the
Spreadshirt page, do all the
editing, choose the T-shirt
you want, choose the mug,
choose the item you want,
and that's it.
And then, well, you buy
and get it delivered.
So from here, instead of
launching the application
directly, they want you
to go back to Drive.
This is something that
can be improved.
This user experience
We would expect the application
to be launched
when you click on the icon
in a new tab page.
And then from inside the
application, you should still
be able to interact
with Drive.
But let's see how it works right
now, and then we will
get back to our suggestions
for improvement.
So if I click on this button, I
launch Drive, which means I
get redirected to Drive.
This is my Drive account.
If I see in the Manage
Apps dialogue--
I see all the applications
I have installed, and
Spreadshirt is here.
I had this installed before, so
I didn't see a new message
in the dialogue saying that I
just installed Spreadshirt.
And this is something
else we would like
Spreadshirt to change.
Let me explain.
When you install Spreadshirt
for the first time, it will
set itself as the default
application for all supported
file types.
Spreadshirt supports all
image file types.
But I don't think that's what
a lot of users want as the
default viewer for images.
Let me show what
happens if this
application is set as default.
I set it as default.
I have an image here.
As a user, what I would expect
by clicking on this image is
that the image is open
in the viewer.
But now if I click on it and
Spreadshirt is the default
application, when I do
that, I'm brought
into Spreadshirt directory.
So let me make this bigger.
This is the first time I
ran the application, or
Spreadshirt.
And the application has to
request access to some of my
data, for instance, the file
I just tried to send.
So this is the standard
auth dialogue.
It is important, as always, to
read what the application
wants from you.
So the application is requesting
permission to view
basic information about
my account.
That's normal.
So it wants my name It wants
some other information.
They are all bundled together.
So if they want my name, they
have to get all this
information together.
But this is normal,
so I'm fine.
They want to see my
email address.
This is totally fine.
They might want this to link
my account to their
Spreadshirt account.
Remember that Spreadshirt is
a website that lives there
without Drive.
So you as a Spreadshirt user can
go there directly instead
of starting from Drive.
And maybe you have an account
there already.
So with this information, they
can realize that you are the
same user that already
has an account there.
And finally, the third piece of
information they want from
me is the ability to view and
manage Google Drive files that
I've opened or created
with this app.
This is a very good.
They're following our
recommendations.
What they're asking here is to
have access to those files
that I'm sending to Spreadshirt
and only those.
They don't want access
to all my files.
They don't need access
They only need access to that
specific image that I send to
Spreadshirt every
time I do it.
And this is exactly what
this permission
request is asking for.
So this is perfect.
I'm going to allow
access to them.
When I do, my file is
going to be loaded
into Spreadshirt which--
it's not working at the
moment, which is fun.
So, well, let me explain
how this works.
So maybe we try this again.
When we go back to Spreadshirt,
what we get is
Flash application that you can
use to design your item.
With this Flash application,
you can select the item.
You can move your design, your
drawing at the center, the
back, everywhere.
You can rotate the item and
see what they look like.
You can change items,
of course.
And you can add text.
When you're done, you can
request it to be shipped--
well, printed, and shipped--
to you in a single item or
multiple items.
Something that we would like
them to fix here, let's see if
it's still down.
It is, unfortunately.
Maybe we will show
it later again.
But something that happens here
when you use Spreadshirt,
starting from Drive, is that
from inside the Spreadshirt
application, there's no way
to get a file from Drive.
So if you start from Drive,
pick a file and send it to
Spreadshirt, that
works correctly.
If you start from Spreadshirt
and want to get a file, that
is not supported.
We covered this use case in our
documentation, and now I
have it open here, so
that I can show it.
What they should use, what
Spreadshirt should use and
what we recommend a lot of other
applications to use is
the Google Picker API.
This is a JavaScript API that
is part of the Google Drive
SDK that allows applications
to open a standard file
dialogue, the same file dialogue
that Google uses and
that all other applications
use.
So it's well known
to the users.
And this dialogue allows
them to open files
or even upload them.
Spreadshirt probably doesn't
need to upload files back into
Drive, but they might need to
open a file from Drive.
So all applications that can
open files from Drive should
probably implement
these two flows--
open a file directly from Drive,
and also embedding the
picker inside the application so
that the user doesn't have
to leave your application.
Remember that if the user has
to leave your application,
they might not come back.
So you don't want them to
leave your application.
That's why you should embed
the picker in your
application.
And this is one of our
suggestions for Spreadshirt.
Let's see.
Another thing we want them to
do, and this is documented
here, is to add the ability to
save your products whenever
you design a product in
Spreadshirt back to Drive.
So right now with Spreadshirt,
with the application, you can
save your products in your
Spreadshirt account.
So there is a way
to save them.
But we think it would be natural
to store those edits,
those designs, those products
you've created-- say, your
T-shirt with your
company logo--
into Drive.
When you save a file
into Drive you have
basically two options.
You can save the actual file, or
you can save a shortcut to
a file that is saved
somewhere else.
We don't know anything about
the file format that
Spreadshirt supports, how
they're saving their designs
in Spreadshirt.
And as they already have a way
to save those files in their
back end, I don't think it
really makes sense for them to
save some files into Drive
and some other files into
Spreadshirt.
What does make sense is
to save what we call a
shortcut to a file.
So remember, this is a new
thing we have in the
Google Drive SDK.
You can save a pointer, a link
to a file that is stored
somewhere else.
We call it shortcut.
So what I think Spreadshirt
should do is, whenever you
want, whenever you want to store
a copy of your design,
they should allow you to
save it into Drive.
When you're saving to Drive,
what you actually save is a
shortcut that contains just an
ID or something that is unique
for Spreadshirt, and
that allows them to
restore that item.
So they save a shortcut,
and they then link the
shortcut to the files.
For the user, the user
experience is exactly the same
as if they were just storing
a file, the real file.
But for the developer, this is
different, because they're not
sending us their files.
They're only sending us
IDs or a link to them.
Another new thing we just added,
we announced it last
Thursday right here in GDL,
Google Developers Live, is the
ability to add thumbnails
to files.
Let's say Spreadshirt
saves the files to
Drive, as I just suggested.
They're going to save
a shortcut.
Being the file a shortcut,
Google cannot know anything
about the file content itself.
So Google cannot generate a
thumbnail for that file.
What a developer can do is
provide us with a thumbnail
that they generated.
So Spreadshirt knows what any
given product is and how it
looks like.
For instance, if it's a T-shirt,
they can send us a
thumbnail that looks like a
T-shirt so that users can
easily spot them when they look
for a specific item in
their Drive list.
This is also documented.
So we covered it last week,
so you can watch the
video if you want.
But it's also covered by
our documentation.
So we have a specific section
on uploading thumbnails.
We support different file
formats, so you can upload the
thumbnails as PNGs, or
a GIF, or JPEGs.
Now, we have some restrictions
on the file size and so on,
and you can read all of them
in the documentation.
It's very easy.
It is just an additional
field in your request.
And if you're using one of our
client libraries, all of them
are updated to support it.
So we strongly recommend
developers with their own
custom file format or developers
with shortcuts to
store a thumbnail for
us so that the user
experience is better.
And users will--
well, are more likely
to-- spot your files
in their file list.
Just before I try again to run
Spreadshirt, otherwise, we
just wrap it up here and maybe
we cover it again later, maybe
when they address all
these comments.
Maybe they're good,
maybe they're not.
I mean the comments.
I said that one of the things
that the application does that
we'd like it to change is that
it sets itself as the default
application.
I showed it in the Manage
Apps dialogue of Drive.
So what I would like is not to
set itself as default, but
only to set itself as a
secondary application to open
those files.
So let's say I uncheck this
used by default checkbox.
What I see here is that if I
try to open an image from
Drive, it opens in the viewer,
which is what most people
would do, because they probably
have photos, and they
want to see them first.
But if I want to open them in
Spreadshirt, all I have to do
is right click, select Open
With, and select one of the
application that supports
this file type.
And Spreadshirt is
one of them.
So same flow, and
I still open the
application from inside Drive.
And the application
is now working.
There was some issues--
temporary issues.
So I can show you what
I was talking about.
Oh, still not working properly,
because it should
show my image here.
So this is the application.
Well, assume you have
my image here.
You can select any item, and
then you can, assuming this
was one of my designs, you can
have it here in the center of
the T-shirt.
And then you select the size,
select the item, and then
you're done.
So I was saying about the
default file type, and that's
my last suggestion for today.
So when you write an application
and you write your
listing, you select what file
types and extensions you want
your application to open as
default or as secondary.
This is done in the Google API's
console, and this is
documented in our Google Drive
SDK documentation.
So what Spreadshirt I guess is
doing is setting the image
file types as primary types.
Instead, I would recommend
them to list them
as secondary types.
To show you how this is done,
I have the Google API's
console open.
This is where you configure all
the marketplace Google Web
Store, Chrome Web Store listing
details for your
application.
For instance, what the
application icon is, and you
define some of your parameters
like credentials and so on.
And the thing I'm talking about
is the default MIME
types, and default file
extension, and secondary MIME
times and secondary
file extension.
I think they should set them
here instead of default ones.
And that will probably provide
users with a slightly better
experience.
Or at least, I don't want some
user to be annoyed by the fact
that their default file viewer
is being overwritten by
another application.
So just another comment.
OK, so to wrap it up,
Spreadshirt Designer is new.
It's on the Chrome
Web Store now.
You might probably know it
already, because you used it
to print your T-shirts.
If you want now, you can use
it with Google Drive.
And I'm pretty sure it's going
to be better and better with
our suggestions and maybe
your suggestions.
Remember that with the Chrome
Web Store, you can and are
invited to write reviews.
So if you have suggestions,
please write them down here in
the Chrome Web Store page.
And if you have any comments or
questions for us or if you
want your application to be
featured in one of our Google
Developers Live events, please
reach out to us.
We are always available on
Google+, and on Stack Overflow
for technical questions.
With that, thank you for
joining me at Google
Developers Live.
I hope you liked it.
And see you next time.
Bye bye.
[ELECTRONIC MUSIC PLAYING]